my worry is this if I had enough said
this on bar rescue if there's 60
motorcycles in front of a bar there's a
bunch of people that won't go to that
bar right if there's a bunch of people
dressed in gang colors in front of a bar
there's people who won't go in that bar
today if there's a bunch of people in
front of a bar that look you're
responsible is it relates to kovat
they're customers that won't go in that
bar it's no different this is the Rubin
report and I'm Dave Rubin reminder
everybody to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and tap that notification bell
so you see our new videos in your feed
and joining me today is the host and
executive producer of bar rescue
the chairman and CEO of Taffer dynamics
and creator of NFL Sunday I didn't know
that one Jon Taffer welcome to the Rubin
report good to be here Dave I am really
glad to be talking to you today because
as you know we're kicking off a small
business week here and I'm gonna be
talking to business owners all over the
country and I think at least one in
Canada about how to reopen how to get
businesses going again how to get the
economy going again everything else and
I thought you'd be a fun guy to to kick
this off with so first off I can see
you're sitting in front of a bar right
there where are you what's going on in
your world at the moment before we get
into business well this is my I'm in my
home bar in my home in Las Vegas so this
this is which I've turned into a studio
lately so we have our companies based
here in Vegas I've lived here in Vegas
for about eight years and we moved all
of our equipment here to my house so
I've been working from home I think I'm
on my 93rd day at home since we closed
down production
now I'll go out on occasion I've done
one or two remotes for some news
channels I did a couple of Fox pieces I
did an MSNBC piece where we went out on
the strip and did it but I've maintained
serious distances and and I'm one of the
more cautious ones in our society I
think yeah so I was reading a bit about
that so you you are definitely on the on
the more cautious side of it but I
suspect as a guy like you who you like
getting out there and going across the
country and talking to people and and
you know sometimes yelling at people and
getting pretty emotional people
you must kind of miss that that human
interaction thing right Oh big time
a matter of fact Dave and I haven't told
anyone this so I'll tell you this today
I have a 45-foot tour bus and I'm
leaving next Tuesday to go across the
country in my bus oh wow and I'm doing
it just to get out there I can see some
family along the way but it's a safe way
to travel these days so I'll be out
there and traveling around the country
for the next three to five weeks so how
did the whole shutdown affect production
for bar rescue were you guys producing
right now where were you in a break or
are you coming back soon we're yet no we
were actually producing and right in the
middle of our last episode we had eight
more to do for the season we were doing
I think 28 for this season and the first
of the last episode we started to sense
things were going on we changed our
production style I was separated from
customers we changed camera angles and
stuff to try to make it all work and at
the end of that episode we were given a
choice to to by the network to either
proceed or not and we chose to proceed
for another week but then about three
hours later we got the call from the
network that everything was being closed
down and that was uh about 93 days ago
so we shut that down we had eight more
left on the schedule and everybody's
scattered and went home so I don't know
what you'll make of this but I have only
watched two reality shows in my entire
life I watched The Apprentice with Trump
and I watch bar rescue with you so I'm
not sure what that means about the
company that you keep but there is
something about bar rescue that it just
it checks off all the boxes for me
because it's very human it's dealing
with struggle it's dealing with finances
it's dealing with often with family
interactions personal interactions
business the whole thing where did the
idea for the show originally come from I
mean I know you've been in that world
forever but really the genesis of the
show well I've been as you said I've
been I've been in the industry for a
long long time and I have the most
popular seminar
in the industry before I was on TV and I
gave a speech in Vegas at Caesar's
Palace and the end of the speech
somebody came up to me David said you
should be on TV so I wrote up this thing
that was originally called on the boy on
the rocks and it was a little like
Mission Impossible it started with me
with files and I'd pull out the
mixologist and then I'd pull out the
chef's letter like Mission Impossible
started and then I'd go in and do these
rescues and I knew I had an advantage
because I wasn't the chef so I didn't
migrate to the kitchen I went everywhere
right so I focused much more on other
areas of the business than a chef did I
wrote this up and I had done business
with Paramount before in a restaurant
space as a licensee so I went back to my
friends who ran paramount television
with my write-up I was real excited Dave
and they looked at me they said John
you'll never be on television
you're too you're too old you're not
good-looking enough it'll never happen
so I went and I shot my own sizzle wheel
the next week with some friends in
Redondo Beach at a friend's bar and sent
that sizzle reel to for production
companies who I had no relationship with
just emailed it to their development
people and I got four offers within
three weeks so I then navigated through
those offers and I wasn't in the
television business so I didn't
understand run clauses and all the
likeness write clauses and all the
things that are particular to an
entertainment contract so I got myself
an entertainment manager and an
entertainment lawyer and we put the deal
together and in less than a year from
when that person told me I'd never be on
TV the show premiered we're now a
hundred and ninety six episodes in with
four episodes from 200 which is a big
record in my industry show is generated
now I think it's close to eight hundred
million dollars worth the revenue and
it's one of the most successful reality
shows of all time and it just shows
don't give up Dave when somebody else
says no maybe the yes should be stronger
in your own mind yeah well that's such a
consistent message in the show but you
know I'm here in LA for people that
don't know how this biz works the idea
that you sent four blank pitches you
know not not that we're asked for or
came from an agency and got four
responses back I mean that that's got to
be unheard of but I assure you I've sent
enough pitches to these people to know
that that's
that's pretty good well I guess it's
sometimes its timing day but you know I
guess I didn't realize it at the time
but 196 episodes into this I guess I'm
pretty good at it and you know my my
secret has been to resist production
from the get-go and I'm different than a
lot of reality TV stars and Trump I
think was this way on Celebrity
Apprentice he already had his money I
already had my success so I wasn't gonna
sell my soul to be on television it was
gonna be real or I wasn't gonna do it
so the behind the scenes in bar rescue
is almost nil I get no briefing I don't
watch any videos I don't go to the
places in advance I've never met two
people before I get about a 60 second
briefing right before I get into the SUV
and everything else I learned it when
you do and I think that's why the show
is successful because you'll know fake
in a second Dave yeah well one of the
things I've heard you say is that fixing
bars is easy fixing people is hard
did you realize going into it how much
of it was just gonna be dealing with
like the psychology of of people because
usually that seems to be what you're
fixing you go in and fix the bar after
but you're really fixing the people
first and that was sort of an evolution
honestly because when I started this I
was a consultant and I was a very well
known consultant so I had very
well-known clients right so my clients
are people like Marriott corporation and
how are they in Zink and Fridays and you
know companies like that so I never knew
this level of failure even existed Dave
I never saw anything like this before in
my life
so when I said to the network I want you
guys find me real failures I don't want
this easy let's make this real I never
comprehended this I mean to think that
somebody's 50 years old they half a
million dollars in debt living in your
parents basement with their child
losing $30,000 a month out of money you
know no credit and they're still going
it's it's remarkable and you know most
of these people have two to three weeks
left and then they're done anyway so it
really is a last chance for them so I
know I could do the whole hour on bar
rescue with you but how much of the
interactions like I get you're being
real and you just learn from them do you
sense it's always this thing where you
see people suddenly doing these
things right before we started I said I
was watching one yesterday doing cardio
where this there's this woman who's an
owner of a bar she's probably in her
mid-50s she's got you know she's got big
boobs she has people doing shots you
know off a rack like like some of it
seems like it's like too crazy to be
real and yet I suspect it probably isn't
well it no it's completely real
everything is completely real there are
no actors there's no scripts there's no
reshoots it is completely real and when
I looked at her and I hope I can say
this on this podcast when I looked at
her and said I can help your sagging
business I don't know if I can help your
saggy boobs I know I said that to her
for a reason I wanted to embarrass her
and you know when I started bar rescue
David was all about dirty bars and you
know remodels and you know several
episodes into it I realized how flawed
these owners were to be in those
situations and if I didn't change them I
couldn't change anything and it was
about a hundred and twenty episodes in
believe it or not I was in Detroit
Michigan with a female owner of a bar I
think I named the proving grounds and I
looked at and I said why are you failing
and Dave she looked at me in the eyes
and said to me I am failing because of
the euro in Greece now this was in
suburban Detroit Michigan and at that
moment I realized that a hundred and
twenty times earlier I had asked these
business owners why are they failing and
never once Dave did anyone ever look at
me and said I'm failing because of me
John not once
so I realized wait a minute if she goes
home and blames the Euro on her failure
she has no reason to change they look in
the mirror in the morning and she'll say
that damn euro taking me down but if she
looked in a mirror and said I'm failing
because of me she wouldn't like that she
would change that hit me a couple of
years ago or three years ago and I
realized that excuses are the common
denominator of failure and then I
thought to myself a little farther what
is an excuse an excuses the
reconciliation of a mistake if you did
something I shouldn't have you didn't do
something you should have or you screwed
up or you wouldn't need the excuse so an
excuse is your way of making yourself
feel good
your own failure it's the most
paralyzing thing in business as an
excuse so when I realized that I said to
myself wow I think I found a common
denominator of failure if I can get
excuses out of people I can take the
things away from them that paralyze them
that caused them to hesitate and pause
so then I said what are the biggest
excuses that we deal with well fear is a
big one I'm scared to do it I'm scared
to do it
but what we're scared of means that
people have already done I'm not talking
about standing on the edge of a cliff
obviously but you know in business and
risk I mean these aren't new things fear
other people have done this fear is BS
in my view and then I look at scarcity
well the money will tell that to Steven
jobs in his garage scarcity and that I
love to excuse circumstance well you
know it's a recession I can't make money
was the big one years ago people got
rich during the recession a lot of
people did so during our pandemic look
at house hand sanitizer companies and
mass companies and look at how these
industries somebody's making money
during all of these things and then I
looked at you know the other excuses you
know and and I came up and I realized
that if I can take these excuses out of
people's lives
I can stop what paralyzes them so that
all happened in that Detroit episode and
from that I wrote the book don't BS
yourself cut the excuses that are
holding you back which made it to the
New York Times bestseller list and I'm
very very proud of that book because
when you finish it excuses won't work
for you anymore
now your self accountable now when you
look in the mirror in the morning you
will blame yourself and you should yeah
well and that's what seems to be the
consistent consistent message throughout
the shows that the owner usually is
making all sorts of excuses for all
sorts of things and if you can fix that
guy or that girl then then the rest of
the pieces do fall into place do you
guys ever do look backs where you're
trying to figure out well who who
actually succeeded after this or who who
the next day after they got their
brand-new beautiful bar just screwed up
the whole thing because I'm sure that
happens to ya there's a website called
bar rescue updates it's an independent
website we have nothing to do with it
it travels on success of bar rescue and
now everybody's clothes but pre-pandemic
we were tracking at about 68 to 70
percent success factor now I don't know
what their definition of success was
they have its open three years later it
to you I don't know but I know that they
had us tracking out about it 68 percent
it was also a newspaper article that
rated to two other restaurant
conversions shows and I won't mention
the shows or the hosts but there's three
of us that tend to claim this space my
show rent about a 68 percent success
factor the other two are in the 20s so
I'm very I'm very pleased with what we
do I go at it as a consultant and the
cameras are along for the trip I don't
go at it as a TV host then a consulting
is along for the trip and I think that's
why we're successful alright cool so as
I said I I love the show so I could talk
about it for an hour but I do want to
talk answer the question I didn't ask
you a question yes we did 20 back to the
bar episodes also ruie went back and
looked them and I think those are on the
Paramount website and those were sort of
fun to go okay I'm gonna have to check
those out so you mentioned a little bit
about your career before all this and
consulting and all that when I was doing
a little research this morning I saw
that you used to work at the Troubadour
in West Hollywood I used to live about a
block from there I've been to a bunch of
a bunch of different events over there
can you tell me a little bit about how
you got into foodservice the early
beginnings of your career where your
sort of ethos around personal
responsibility and and the rest of it
came from well when I was young that
play I was a very serious musician I
took drum lessons to nine years it was
very good I still have a drum set
upstairs in my office I was very good
and so I wanted to be a musician but my
family and there's another side of me
that wanted to be going to business to
make a long story short I went to
University of Denver and majored in
political science and minored in
cultural anthropology which I love the
study of primates and what makes us
think and understanding our primal
behaviors and such and I started tending
bar in college and one thing led to
another and to chase my music career and
now that I had a bartending skill I went
to Los Angeles got an apartment to the
Oakwood apartments in Studio City back
then which had quite a social hot tub
scene back in those days
I got a job in the Troubadour because it
connected bartending and music for me
and then evolved to be manager of the
Troubadour and also worked in Barney's
Beanery down the street and managed
Barney's oh yeah yeah Phil there
sure so uh that was my real beginnings
when I took over the Troubadour we had
about eight inches of water on the floor
in the kitchen that was flooded and we
had no money and Doug Westin the owner
may he rest in peace back then had
recreational drug habits and I would
close the Troubadour and I'd put $800 or
whatever in a four safe and I'd have to
come back at 8:30 in the morning to get
that $800 out to pay for the liquor
because everything was co dicus we had
no credit and I'd come in the morning
and the money would be gone cuz Doug
took it for drugs the night before so I
had to run this business in the most
unfavorable of ways I had no money he
kept taking the money I started taking
it home at night so he couldn't get it
in the morning I had a flood in the
kitchen that we didn't have the money to
fix
I got palettes wooden pallets we threw
him on the kitchen floor so he could
walk over the water rather than and have
dough and that's how we opened the
Troubadour and I coordinated something
called the 25th anniversary of the
troubadour and we got everybody from
George Carlin to Linda Ronstadt all of
them to come back during that month and
we made the money and stabilized
operations wow that's incredible so then
so then from there where did you go what
are those missing ears between that and
and what was all of you now so from
there actually I worked in Barney's
Beanery a short time before the
Troubadour then went then to the
troubadour then from the troubadour I
got an offer to be a state manager for a
restaurant chain out of Florida called
beefsteak Charlie's believe it or not oh
yeah I remember being in early and they
had the huge salad bar and all that and
I thought that was exciting to learn the
food business so I went and I did that
and I worked out in Florida ran near
Fort Lauderdale restaurant and a couple
of other restaurants in Florida and then
I received the phone call from a
headhunter and this one changed my life
and I was recruited to go up and be a
food and beverage director at
Grossinger's the largest resort in
America upstate New York 1700 guestrooms
three nine hole golf courses our own
Lake our own Ski Mountain
America's first snow making
equipment so I went up there that that's
Catskills is that Catskill Mountains you
bet grocer yes
two Biggie's with a Concord and
Grossinger's up there so yeah I worked
as I worked the family and was food and
beverage director and worked there for a
few years really learn the resort
business to convention business and a
hotel business so now I had run a
nightclub a great bar a chain of steak
houses and now I'm running food and
beverage at a large convention resort
hotel that rounded out my experience
pretty well I got a phone call from the
same headhunter a couple years later
said John I got a client who's building
the greatest nightclub in the world he
wants you to come run it and his name
was Leon Altemus in Philadelphia and he
was creating pulsations nightclub and
pulsations nightclub had a four and a
half tonne spaceship 27 feet in diameter
people can google it online that came
down and dropped a four hundred thousand
dollar robot on the dance floor and it
was great it was rated as the greatest
nightclub in the world I worked on that
for a few years opening an operating
pulsations nightclub and now I had run a
a mega venue and from Grossinger's then
I was started my own company actually
enough I'm forgetting a step from
Grossinger's I was hired by a hotel
management company out of Chicago called
PMS management and I was a hotel general
manager and then a vice president of
sales and marketing for this company
that had 28 hotels for about four years
when I left that company that was 1986 I
started my own consulting company
because tax codes had changed Dave and
hotels couldn't write off the things
they used to write off now so
restaurants had to make money they
couldn't be guest amenities anymore bars
had to make money you know these had to
be profit centers not just amenities so
I left that company started my own
company Taffer dynamics and my first
client was that company so they let me
start my company and gave me a number of
contracts and then in 1989 I built my
first owned operation in st. Louis a
place called Lynn Dickies in st. Louis
Union Station and then from there I was
approached by Simon Property Group to do
a few restaurants in Wall of America in
Minnesota so I went up to Minneapolis I
opened the Alamo grill Gators and
original sports bar another concept
that we worked on up in a mall of
America that one really changed my life
and then I took Alamo Grill turned it
into a chain of steak houses took it
public then reversed it into another
public company and left Woodstock in a
huge a Canadian entity and then I was in
business I had owned I had taken a
public I had run hotels bars restaurants
concert venues I had taken companies
public taking companies profit uh I was
really ready and that of course was a
long time ago so since then I've
consulted to some of the greatest
companies in the world so I always tell
people during my consulting practice in
young years I made every mistake there
was to make and that's why I got really
good at it and now I am I'm probably one
of the best out of in the world it's
funny because when I hear you talk about
your resume it's like wow the fact that
I really only know this guy as you know
a sort of reality TV host but it's a lot
of decades of stuff I mean you just went
across the the food service industry and
did pretty much is there anything you
didn't do like do you see any holes in
that industry that you that you really
didn't do or weren't part of no I know
every type of venue from concert venues
to outdoor arenas inside venues fine
dining restaurants casual dining fast
food I mean I've been in every one of
these sectors as either an owner
operator management company or
consultant I really do know every aspect
of this business and make no mistake
Dave that helps and I think it's very
important that people in casual dining
have an understanding of upscale dining
because they impact each other and there
are things and service sequencing and
things that one can learn in one segment
from another one category from another
fast-food is another great example you
know the transactional style of fast
food now has to exist in full-service
restaurants because of Kovan in contact
listen so so I think that broadness of
appeal has really helped me particularly
my hotel background and resort
background has been very helpful for me
can you talk about just some of the
basic principles that you try to bring
to any of the businesses that you're
coaching or working on because as I said
since we're doing this as Small Business
Week we're going to talk to people not
just in the food service industry but
just some of the principles that you
think actually build solid strong
businesses that can actually survive
when we go through you know terrible
situations like we're going through
right now well you know I think that a
couple of things one I don't think that
you're doing a podcast or a broadcast
right now I don't believe that I don't
believe that's your product I believe
that's your vehicle your product is
reactions if your audience doesn't react
to what you do then it serves no purpose
so you're not in the content business
you're in a reaction business content is
your vehicle it's not your product
that's the first thing I learned when I
was younger that cook in the kitchen is
not making an entree he's not making a
product he's creating a reaction
he's the vehicle when that plate hits
the table Dave one of two things happens
either you sit up and you react to it or
you don't that reaction is the product
so I suggest that cell phone companies
don't sell technology they sell
reactions they achieve it through
technology I suggest that every business
is in a reaction business I own the term
reaction management my first book raised
a bar was all about reaction management
and understanding and this comes out of
my cultural anthropology training as
well understanding the primal instincts
of what you react to is a consumer so I
believe that we don't play music we play
reactions we achieve it through music we
don't make drinks we make reactions we
achieve that through drinks so I am in
the business of creating human reactions
period end of discussion and he or she
who creates the best reactions in my
business wins end of story
that's the business that we're in now we
can dissect that interconnectivity and
engagement and pace an environment but
every one of those things has to create
reaction pace is about reaction go to a
fine steak house they walk really slow
go to a Denny's they walk really fast if
the waiter walks too fast in a fine
steak house that steak isn't worth $80
anymore is it so these things all affect
reactions and reactions drive consumer
behavior reactions drive transactions
period it isn't the other way around so
when I take a look at the whole science
of reactions then in our corporate
training we created something else as a
term that we own called gross gross then
for guest reaction opportunity windows
and other businesses we call it CROs
customer reaction opportunity windows
points where I can create a reaction in
you I spec them
I designed them right into the business
I want to design this right into that
business so I'm designing not a plane
I'm designing a reaction and I'll design
that plate a hundred freaking times
until you sit up and that's the business
that we are all in and he or she no
matter what business there we are gonna
create the best reactions of all now if
we take a look at the current situation
where right now if we can talk about the
pandemic for a moment or two yeah yeah
absolutely you know I said this four
months ago and I was one of the first
ones to say it and research now shows
that I was 2% off when this started I
said people are gonna come back in 2/3
the first third is the quick third
they're gonna come right out again when
the doors open they're younger they're a
little fearless right they're gonna come
out they might not wear masks we're
seeing that first third now according to
medics according to research its 31% I
projected 1/3 the second third I called
a reserved third they want to watch for
a couple weeks Dave they want to see
what happens you know there's there a
surge how do the restaurants look does
it look safe for people wearing massive
a mat if it feels good and looks good
the reserved third will go out now we
got two thirds the third third is the
certain third they're not going anywhere
they are certain that they're safe so a
vaccine or a rock-solid treatment needs
to emerge before they'll come out the
issue is that the third third has the
money it tends to be an older
demographic a more affluent demographic
greater disposable income number they
tend to feed the luxury sector more than
the first third and the second third so
there's a demographic reality to this as
these businesses shuffle through it for
example I'm here in Las Vegas we've been
open for about a week we're doing pretty
well but we're finding the first
customers who come are value oriented
they're coming they're there that first
third they're younger they don't have
high despo so they're very value
oriented so we better come out of the
gate with value propositions when the
second third comes out what what are the
kinds of things what are the kinds of
things that you guys are doing in Vegas
or that you're seeing being done to
address that well the average casino has
about 800 policy changes in it from from
non-invasive temperature testing
automatically as you walk through the
door the proper
the contactless check into only one or
two people in elevators that are pleased
and managing each elevator for to
sanitize chips and cards and when you're
finished with a slot machine it turns
off and it can turn on again until it's
sanitized and there's a lock and a key
system on it so they've done all sorts
of things uh to make it successful but
you know Dave what worries me is when we
look at these thirds is obviously
there's a progress we need to go through
and let me ask you a question if I can
if you were gonna bail out tonight in a
restaurant that was open and there was a
crowd of people in that front of that
restaurant and none of them were
marrying wearing masks would you go in
so it's interesting so I'll tell you I
have only been to one restaurant since
this all happened it was last week it
was a restaurant right by my house just
a burger joint bar that I go to every
now and again the waitress I was not
wearing a mask there and it was pretty
sporadic so you know I was with one
person the waitress was wearing a mask
and a face guard and you know it's it's
not that comfortable we you know this
you you need to read people's faces to
feel comfortable it feels sort of weird
with all that I think for me at this
point as a relatively young healthy
person if I went to a nice restaurant
let's say in Beverly Hills or something
like that
I would be okay if people were not
wearing stuff I actually would be okay
with that but I don't think I don't
consider myself in the last third that
you just talked about I think I'm
somewhere between the first third and
the second third I think and also you
know here in Los Angeles where we've
been closed for so long I think I'm also
having like a reverse reaction which I
think a lot of people are having which
is like let's just go just go and see
what happens yeah yeah now I worry about
a irresponsibility not on a part of
restaurant owners you know I'm concerned
Dave that a restaurant does everything
right it sanitizes puts their employees
in the proper gear
there's all the procedures in the
kitchen all the PPE attire you know has
everything exactly right but then a
bunch of customers come in without masks
create a bad impression pictures go on
social media of this place pack and then
all of the portion of society that wants
to wear masks
we'll never go there so there's a real
challenge for business today and I think
I know the answer but I'm not quite sure
if my answer is right if you and this is
deep day but if you're in a bar business
and you said okay I'm gonna play country
music no rock and roll people are coming
you've made a decision that's gonna
completely segment your business to
country people only so you're not you're
gonna see some boots you're gonna see
some hats you're not gonna see a lot of
Armani suits probably and it's gonna be
a country environment let's say you
chose I don't want to do it I'm gonna
play rock and roll in my bar okay no
country people there no hip-hop people
there you just segmented your business
to a portion of the population let's say
you say I'm gonna play hip hop same deal
no country no rock you segmented
yourself into a certain segment of the
population my point is this is the mask
wearers and is the non mask wearers and
I think that restaurants are going to be
put in a position where they're gonna
have to choose just like that music
segmentation either you have to wear a
mask in my restaurant when you're not
eating
you have to Ameri west where you're
wearing outside or you don't but I don't
think mixing it is gonna work long term
and that's a really tough choice and
nobody's talking about this in the
industry do it or don't do it what do we
have to do is and it's a segmenting
decision just like music is or price
points are so I'm of the belief that
restaurants need to pick and I'm of the
belief for long term sustainability and
here's what I worry about we are living
in a culture of accountability today
Piko people go out have a bad meal it's
all over Yelp in a matter of minutes
right dirty all so if people get sick in
a restaurant and it's traced back to a
restaurant done case closed that place
will never open again in New York
they're gonna take liquor licenses away
if customers act irresponsibly so we're
at a turning point as an industry are we
going to allow the behavior of customers
to destroy our investment or are we
gonna regulate that behavior the
nightclub business has been doing this
for years by segmenting by music
segmenting by dress codes and doing
segmentation we survived in a segmented
world since I got in this business all
these years ago I don't believe that we
can succeed as an industry if we don't
choose what size
we're on and if we choose to run in an
unprotected environment and choose to
not do some of these processes that can
keep people safe we may pay the ultimate
price and the ultimate price is not only
getting somebody sick or potentially
killing them but destroying your
business so I take an opposite position
to you and and I'm not sure that I would
let you in my restaurant or stand in
front of it without a mask yeah and I I
totally hear you I it's it's it's a
personal choice not only for the the
individual consumer but obviously for
the for the owner of the bar or
restaurant do you think what makes it
even more muddled what confuses it even
more is that it's one thing if you're
walking into a clothing store and you're
wearing a mask well you're not using
your mouth you're not using your face at
a restaurant it's like well wait a
minute I can walk in I have to wear
masks let's say when I walk in but we do
know I have to drink through my mouth I
have to eat through my mouth so we so
there's these sort of inconsistencies
where it's like people are just like
more than why am i doing it at all like
it's just it's just the natural
questions that arise well if there's
spacing at the tables and people are
standing in front of the restaurant
without that level of spacing I think
it's reasonable for us to say we'd
appreciate you wearing a mask until
you're seated right seems seems like a
simple definition my worry is this if I
had enough said to Sun bar rescue if
there's 60 motorcycles in front of a bar
there's a bunch of people that won't go
to that bar right if there's a bunch of
people dressed in gang colors in front
of a bar there's people who won't go in
that bar today if there's a bunch of
people in front of a bar that look
you're responsible is it relates to
kovat their customers that won't go in
that bar it's no different
so when you say about how are we going
to be successful there's two issues does
that issue and all of that is driven by
this one premise and bear with me for a
minute David if you you're a burger guy
right you love a good burger yeah oh
yeah oh yeah so let's say that your
favorite burger place in town after this
pandemic you go walk up to it
everybody's packed in there they're not
wearing masks you know they're not even
wearing masks behind the counter the
whole thing just doesn't feel right
but two blocks farther away is your
second favorite burger place farther but
they're green they're tight they're
staff
and mass I mean this place is together
it looks great safe you're now gonna go
to your second favorite burger place
which is farther away than your first
burger place Dave that changes
everything
Trust has now ratcheted to the top so
now you're gonna walk farther to go to
your second favorite burger place
because your first favorite burger place
didn't gain your trust well it's
interesting because yeah well it's
interesting because you're talking about
free-market capitalism and and also
talking about rules but ultimately
you're saying it's it's on people to
make the right choices so if in fact
Trust is ratcheting up to the top of the
motivation list of what businesses I
choose to do business with how do we
build trust and this goes back to your
question how do we get successful now
well if we know that we have thirds then
we if we know we have to build trust for
even for you who's quicker to go out
maybe than I am then how do we build
trust well
Trust isn't words trusses and
advertising campaigns Trust is
transparency right you begin to trust me
as an individual once you get to know me
a little right Trust is built so Trust
is a very difficult emotion to build in
a person so we need to be transparent so
the way we create transparency is by
creating visual standards of what people
see and what they can expect in our
business so for example a few weeks ago
on my social media beta some guys making
lasagna in a kitchen and he posts a
picture of a cook and he's standing in
the stainless steel line and he's laying
over zhonya noodle in the pan and the
post says our famous lasagna will be
ready for curbside pickup at five
o'clock pretty noble effort right guys
not wearing a mask he's wearing a
ballcap from home he's wearing clear
sheet plastic gloves that if somebody
wears in a salon when they do hair color
it's not even food service rated all the
imaging is wrong so if we don't build
trust nobody's gonna eat that fricking
lasagna so we as an industry have to
really understand how to build trust
what are we what are the marketing
communications of trust when you walk up
to the front door of my business we
tell restaurant/bar what looks different
oh they changed this and subliminally
you're saying well they changed it for
me they're keeping me safe this is a
good thing oh I feel good about this I
like this okay this make from one little
thing all of these assumptions go
through your head so what has to be
different I suggest that every business
needs to change something you need to
change their seating layout they need to
change signage in the front they need to
put a podium out front for check-in they
need to do something that sends the
message of trust in a transparent way if
I can send the message of trust in this
world I can get the first third the
second third and a third third if trust
if that first third glam slam shout
social media with untrusting visuals
you're gonna have a hell of a time
getting it to second and third third so
where do you think government and
regulation kind of fit into this because
you know we're hearing all sorts of
arbitrary things or seemingly arbitrary
things every week depending on where you
live you know okay we can be at 50%
restaurant capacity but that's
regardless whether you've done all of
these precautions or not done all of
these precautions and I'm sure you must
be hearing from owners of restaurants
and bars who are saying hey I'll do
everything that I possibly can do I'll
put all the investment and we'll do all
the work but if we can only open at 50%
capacity we there's no way we can
succeed regardless of doing everything
or not doing everything well you know I
I don't disagree with you so new revenue
centers need to be found hence delivery
curbside pickup but there are these
third-party delivery apps are destroying
our industry you know they're the only
people who make money you pay them 25 up
to 35% third party delivery apps so I
begged people on this podcast if you
want to do it to go order or curbside
delivery or to call the restaurant
directly don't call one of these
third-party sources it's a huge deal to
them it's a huge difference in the way
they make money so we have to create
these new opportunities for revenue
models you know I have a friend Tiffany
Derry you've seen her chef Tiffany Derry
on bar rescue
you know her restaurant now does family
meal packs before to go and for $39 you
get an amazing meal with potatoes and
vegetables and chicken and soup and pie
so she's come up with a new way to pack
her product you know we take a look at I
was on a consulting call with a big
brewery in Canada and they have a
merchandising program called from tap to
table doesn't work anymore
now it's from tap to home we got to get
our brand home we got to get delivery
packaging we got to get our brand to
move so I'm with you day but here's the
problem I'm at 50% capacity so I have to
do if I'm had half the capacity I have
to double my hours of revenue so an hour
and a half the lunch doesn't work for me
anymore I need three cores of lunch now
so I need to do early-bird lunch
specials late bird lunch specials early
bird dinner
I gotta generate more hours to offset my
loss in capacity so I got a look at that
which means I have to do some
promotional activity you know free this
free that get this $2 off to drive more
hours of traffic the problem is I've
also increased my labor cost
rike is now doing in three hours what I
used to do in one hour an hour and a
half so it affects the whole economic
model here's my point we have two
challenges in front of us as an industry
one is to sustain ourselves during this
and the second is to have the resources
to launch properly when it ends if we
spend all of our money sustaining
ourselves Dave we are never gonna reopen
with your resources to win if we hold
back our sustaining dollars now and hold
them for when we can open properly I
personally think that's the better
scenario and I've found for very many
friends sure we want to keep our
employees working we want to do
everything we can but it might make
sense to close for a few weeks
and open with a real marketing plan and
an activation plan in a promotion plan
it opened with a bang later when we have
the potential to do so it's hard to
spend the money to do anything with a
bang when you're locked at 50% capacity
you know the other thing that you said
which was important to me was you know
what do we do what did the standards 25%
50% you know blah blah blah blah so I
think it's paramount and I know the NRA
National Restaurant Association not
rifle I know the NRA I always get hate
notes when I put NRA on social media
that you know that I had a buddy in the
food service industry who's always
telling me to going to the NRA meetings
I think they were in Chicago and it was
always very confusing but we
but you know they put together some
wonderful programs and standards that we
can follow to you know to assure
consumer safety I think that there needs
to be some federal standard I do I
believe that and the problem with the
governor's is they tango with the
federal government now there's an ego
thing there's a push and pull in power
we're more divisive than ever before so
a Democratic governor is not gonna
listen to a Republican president no
matter what the standards are if he says
50 percent they're doing 25 and I'm not
being political here but there are
standards that make sense and the
disease can be contracted just as easily
in Florida as at at Oklahoma there's no
chemical difference between the disease
and those places so if there was a
standard that was safe the national
standard you and I could start to feel
comfortable with that standard right so
I think that that's the problem is you
don't know what to expect and every
state is a free-for-all in standards I
think we need a national program I do
and I'm just not sure the states will
agree to it but I'm pushing for it very
heavily that defined space requirements
distancing requirements food service
back to the house requirements so that
everybody knows that it's an even
playing field that you know every
restaurant is in the same playing field
the same economic modeling the same
consumer presence that all changes you
know years ago they've I can remember
when Tempe Arizona put a no-smoking
policy in place it was a little town
nobody else around it did every bar went
broke when that happened you can't do
things Guyana lives on the Tennessee
Kentucky border the guy in Tennessee is
making a fortune the guy in Kentucky is
starving there across the street from
each other cuz the regulations are
different that doesn't work in a
business environment I think we need to
level the playing field create some
national standard of behavior force
that's predictable to you so you know
whether you go to Dave's restaurant or
John's restaurant it's gonna have the
same policies in place we have to get to
that point somehow I believe do you
think we get it well it's interesting I
you know as a general rule I'm a big
states rights guy so I want the states
to be able to set whatever regulations
are as possible because then the
experiment sort of bounces around but as
I say on the show all the time something
like coronavirus
or any virus doesn't respond to states
borders so I think we need something
that blends both state and and federal
would be my short answer on that and I'm
with you a very state rights oriented
vocal as well but you know I think in
this position the problem is that the
actions that I'm just taking Tennessee I
have no issues with Tennessee you know
the issues if somebody works in kind of
C and lives in Kentucky the policies of
Tennessee could be impacting the state
of Kentucky so I think there is a cross
responsibility here particularly near
the borders that we have some standards
of behavior so that no state town or
person is disadvantaged that seems
reasonable to me
yeah well it's always a matter of how do
you how do you get there I suspect we
all want to get to the same thing which
is people back to work and enjoying
themselves do you do you think
regardless of how the the third third
third shakeout III could sort of see
everything going one of two ways one way
would be which would be terrible for the
economy and certainly for the
foodservice industry would be that
people have now just new behaviors we're
used to bringing in food all the time
most of us are cooking more one way or
another and that that behavior will just
sort of continue or there's another part
Amana and I hope it goes more to this
where when we really are on the other
side of this that there's more of a
roaring 20s feeling you know we are in
the 20s now and that there would be more
of a feeling of like yeah let's remember
what it was like to go out there and you
know go to a bar and hang out with your
friends or meet some new people or go to
your favorite restaurant I'm really
missing boa Steakhouse on sunset like to
do that kind of stuff
do you sense we will go one way or the
other I do but I think it might get
split by those thirds a little bit you
know I think that the I think that the
sting is gonna last longer for people of
an older demo I just do and and I think
that the that if I were to do a
prediction I think the luxury dining
sector is gonna be the most challenged
all right I think they're gonna be the
last ones to come out even though they
tend to have more spread dining rooms
anyway they probably lose less seating
which seeks foot separation right
because the tables aren't bunched like
in a casual dining environment you know
I'm very concerned you know there's a
way to look at this - let's say we do
lose 30 to 40% of our restaurants and
bars well in theory
we now have 40% less capacity and
seating but we have about the same
market place so you know I think that
the ones that survive might actually
survive and into a very vibrant market
place and I think I agree with you on a
Roaring Twenties analogy but I think we
need to get to a vaccine and a place
where you know that safety is somewhat
assured how worried are you that small
businesses the guy that just wants to
make a great bar a great restaurant not
not a franchise not a big business but
the guy that wants in his hometown to
just put the greatest restaurant ever
there that they will have looked at what
happened over the last year and be like
you know what the risks risks always I'm
sure you know the numbers for
restaurants and bars if you want to tell
everybody the the failure rates they're
always absurdly high but now the risks
seem almost incalculably high for people
to want to get in on this you know it's
interesting that you mention I own a
franchise called taffer's tavern and we
created this franchise you'll find this
interesting and I'm not doing this as a
plug we two years ago had no labor pool
we were approaching $15 minimum wages
and a labor pool that we did have were
mostly new Americans who didn't speak
English so well so I said I got to
create the casual dining concept of the
future so I want to cut labor costs in
half I want to bring in robotic cooking
robotic ovens eliminate
back-of-the-house create this whole new
restaurant model so I did I worked with
companies like middle B and worked in
test kitchens around the country and
created this kitchen of the future
concept a year ago created called Patras
tavern did our franchisee registration
started to franchise kovat happens we
find out we don't have any raw protein
in our restaurant it's all sous-vide
cooking everything is individually
wrapped prepared and computerized ovens
it's really high quality so we don't
have raw and cooked product we don't
have grease we don't even have hoods so
we have a very different cooking model
it is the kitchen of the future we are
the most coded safe kitchen in the world
we didn't even design it this way so now
we put uniforms on our kitchen staff we
have cameras in the kitchen so you can
see your food be prepared right on your
phone and we created the safest cleanest
kitchen concept
country starting on a whole different
basis so I launched my franchises and
I'm answering your question for you cuz
this is interesting they haven't we sold
a bunch of franchises we sold Washington
we sold the lanta a whole bunch of
territories we're doing very very well
the franchise is going covet hits shoot
sales stop of franchises about 45 days
later we get a phone call from some
people that say listen we're a franchise
company we're interested in buying your
franchise and here's why we want to buy
it now because we think some of the
greatest restaurant locations in America
are going to become available in the
next 90 days and we want to jump on
those locations with a concept that has
good solid economic modeling and you
know it's an interesting I never quite
thought that way so we just sold the
city of Boston we just sold the city of
Washington DC to sophisticated
developers who are now dropping them in
places like Fanueil Hall because these
locations have become available my point
is this there's opportunity now and the
industry is going to go through a shift
there's no question about it but there's
great locations that are going to be
available now there's aggressive
landlords who will give you a very
aggressive deals right now with 10 and
allowing packages and free rent for a
year or two I mean a will bend over
backwards to do those deals so to that
fictitious restaurant guy that we were
just talking about who's scared to do it
maybe this is the time to do it and I
put a fascinating thought model out
there now we have a big to go element
that we've put in in taffer's tavern and
a curbside element so we shifted the
business model post Colvin obviously
Dave but my point is this if you've ever
wanted to be in a restaurant business
one of the highest costs we got is
occupancy and construction today there's
unbelievable opportunity out there don't
just think the COBIT is bad for the
industry it could be good for the
industry too for some people in the end
the interesting yeah well chaos always
brings opportunity I'm actually glad you
brought up the automated kitchen and
mentioned a little bit about the
economics of some of this because it is
something that I talk about a lot on the
show relative to minimum wage and the
rest of it so for you as a guy that why
I know you want to employ people you
want people to feel empowered and feel
like they have some control in their
lives and all that
when you're making those decisions to go
well wait a minute I can't pay these
people $15 an hour because technically
they're not worth it if they don't speak
the language and all that without
getting into all the specifics of that
do you have sort of like almost like a
philosophical struggle there between how
to go ahead and do a new business that
isn't going to hire as many people
potentially but is going to be more of
say a restaurant of the future and
something that's sustainable that's
that's your whole point honestly no
uh-uh and of course there's a personal
fact you want to hire as many people as
you can you know my proudest day is when
I had about 900 employees and I used to
say think to myself every night I put
about a thousand meals on the table
every day I was really proud of that but
you know today my responsibility to
sustain the jobs of the people that work
for me to provide them with an
opportunity that is consistent is gonna
last and provide them with a good income
bigger doesn't necessarily mean more
stable doesn't mean more income for
everyone also there's what about the guy
who built all the robotics who
programmed all the systems they got jobs
that didn't have them before so I don't
think I'm eliminating jobs they think
I'm redistributing those jobs a little
bit into technology plays rather than
just straight hook lines but but you
know I think that that the restaurant
industry is being challenged unlike
others you know there's many states
where tipped employees get paid about
220 an hour and it's an employee tip
credit of you know whatever it is $13 an
hour to adjust their payroll down so
these employees typically make twenty
thirty forty dollars an hour in tips in
many of these places so they make to 20
now and payroll from 220 an hour to $15
is a 600 percent payroll increase there
is no business in the world that can
sustain a 600 percent payroll increase
so I'm trying to protect my industry I'm
trying to protect the people that work
in the industry by creating a stable
economic model so there is no guilt
instability there is no guilt in
following you know economic models that
provide prosperity for those who work
for us so it isn't my choice I'd much
rather be hiring more people but it
isn't something I have any guilt about
yeah I love the answer I mean that
that's the honest answer and
unfortunately we've got a lot of
business owners
these days that would give you the guilt
answer to just sort of pretend they're
doing the right thing as opposed to
actually actually doing the right thing
if somebody if somebody's watching this
right now
and they're young and they always wanted
to get into the biz you know you talked
about a long resume of doing basically
everything what would you recommend I
mean is the first job just to be a
barback or do you have like a specific
idea on how they get in on this yeah you
know I think the most important two jobs
or a line cook in a barback you learn
everything from those two positions or
bartender so you know I'm of the belief
that that you should not go into this
business until you're at least ten bar
and work in a kitchen those are the two
areas where waste occurs those are the
two areas with theft occurs those are
the two hearts of the of the business if
it breaks down there in either of those
places you have no business the worst
thing in the world in a restaurant
industry is to be held hostage to
ignorance I can't tell you how many
friends have had over the years that
have opened restaurants that have never
been in the business before they hire a
chef right they pay Amex amount of hours
a year they're open 60 days the chef
says this is all on me I won equity or
I'm leaving and the guy who owns it
doesn't know how to cook a steak or
doesn't even know one of his own recipes
he's held hostage by his ignorance this
is a challenging business you know think
of a retail store but the t-shirts go
bad after three days how about that
imagine a t-shirt shop that they rot
away after three or four days you know
that there's staff that so we have to
manage production we have to manage
retail management izing manage staff
manage purchasing it's a very difficult
business and you can't do it from a
point of ignorance those are the people
who fail and it's interesting day
because if you look at the statistics
about one of eight restaurants succeed
for first time operator seven of eight
succeed for the second time Wow it's a
fascinating shift in the statistics so
once you've made those mistakes the
first time they've you sort already now
but without the experience you're not in
a very good statistical place with the
experience you're in a far better
statistical place what what resources
can we send people to are you still
doing seminars on sure yeah sure we
the seminars you go to John Taffer calm
matter-of-fact we're working on an
industry webinar in the next couple of
weeks so you can go visit John Taffer
calm you know there's great resources
out there for restaurant people please
go to the National Restaurant
Association site they have wonderful
kovat information great marketing
programs and such
there's another organization a nightclub
and bar show a media group which also
has great information on it and then of
course you know we have our TV t which
is about 40 hours of training content
marketing promotion that we have that's
available on our website also my point
is this you know when this pandemic
started and I'd like to sort of be
positive here for a minute there you
know when this pandemic started I saw
people get paralyzed they didn't know
what to do they were frozen you know my
second book about excuses which we
talked about you know I realized that at
this time great marketers are gonna
bubble to the top aren't they we're
gonna see some amazing stuff great
promoters are gonna bubble to the top
we're gonna see great activations and
programs and online events and great
operators are gonna bubble to the top
we're gonna see incredible things happen
out there so this is a time to mobilize
not paralyze this is a time to think
about what it takes to bubble to the top
dare I say those of us who perceive this
is an opportunity and act the planet can
turn this into an opportunity those of
us who freeze who say oh you know this
isn't the time this isn't I believe
we're gonna be left behind this is all
up to us not the pandemic it is up to us
don't let this pandemic be the excuse
that we talked about that earlier you
know that's just making yourself feel
warm well it's the pandemic that caused
me to fail and I'm gonna say it
it's up to us and at a time like this we
can figure out how to be successful and
a lot of restaurants are gonna do that
well John I don't know that I've ever
felt better about what I do for a living
cuz you didn't yell at me once in 50
minutes so I must be doing okay over
here well you're a great host buddy you
have a great cast and you know I'm proud
to be here with you but I think you do
wonderful work and I think you know
anybody who listens to your podcasts
always learn something about themselves
and their business so keep up the good
work my friend well I really appreciate
it and listen I'm gonna be in Vegas in a
couple weeks for Freedom Fest
if you've got a little time I'd love to
take you out for a drink or a steak or
whatever you're doing these days oh wait
it's probably not gonna be what your are
you gonna want to go out no just a few
places I'll go to there's a few places
I'll go to you bet you bet it's on me
man well I really appreciate it thanks a
lot a pleasure nice to talk with you
there if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
lifestyles instead of non-stop yelling
check out our lifestyle playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlists they're both right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell